[Music]
hey what's up guys mkbhd here and as
some of you may have suspected i have
been using the oneplus nord for
quite a few weeks now actually maybe the
longest i've ever used something
pre-launch but oneplus is one of those
companies where they have a
separate impressions embargo for
unboxings and stuff
and then a reviews embargo which is
smart because then you've created
two separate waves of press about your
product i talked about this on a
waveform podcast episode
so i get it but that means that i can't
share my full review of this guy with
you guys
quite yet but nevertheless here we are
they did their event it's unveiled now
so i figured i'd give you guys this
quick video
of all the official stuff about nord in
one place
so the spec the design the hardware
and some of the important stuff like the
availability
and the price so this is everything you
need to know so we saw the design of
course revealed already in our exclusive
but here's
a better crispy high resolution look at
nord and these two colors here are blue
marble
and gray onyx and it's not bad but
my take is pretty mixed on the design so
remember when carl showed those
prototype designs that they were
considering before they scrapped them
and then went with the more traditional
design
i actually like those designs more than
the one they settled on
like these had a little more character
they had that matte finish
they had a little more unique and
identifiable features
but they ended up going back here to a
more recognizable
oneplus design which basically means the
vertical camera module on the back
which fair you know that's been a
oneplus thing for a little while but
i kind of think it takes away from the
character i mean look at this
this is not the nord this is the oppo
reno 3 pro it just looks like yet
another version of kind of the same
phone
i'm just saying but the point of the
oneplus nord is
to move down in price so we've all heard
the oneplus story
a thousand times but they've been
creeping up and up and up slowly in
price over the years
as they approach flagship status and use
more and more expensive parts
and so people started to wonder are they
just leaving the whole cheap phone thing
are they abandoning what got them so
many fans in the first place which was
great phones for a low price
and so with nord they're back at that
and to be honest it seems like this is
about as good as an
overall package as you're going to get
for the price and that price
is 3.99 euros
specifically because this phone isn't
available in the us or north america at
all but we'll get to that in a second so
for that price you're getting
a lot so in the spec department that's a
snapdragon 765g
eight gigs of ram and 128 gigs of
storage but there's also a 12
256 model and then up front is a flat
6.4 inch 1080p 90 hertz amoled display
with the fingerprint reader underneath
and 180 hertz touch sampling rate
that's pretty nice for this price now
you can tell it's not quite the tippy
top flagship stuff we expect
for higher prices of course a 900 or
thousand dollar phone will have
a higher refresh rate and even higher
resolution and just overall better
quality panels but even at 1080p here
you're looking at over 400 pixels per
inch and most people spending 400 bucks
on a phone can't tell the difference
between 90 hertz and 120 hertz
and the whole thing gets pretty close to
the bezels basically this does not feel
like a cheap phone screen at all
and it's also got the dual hole punch
cutout at the front
and just overall it's a pretty nice
display the fingerprint reader from what
i can tell is about the same as what
i've seen in other oneplus phones it's
optical
and it's pretty low on the phone so it's
actually easy to reach
and then behind that display powering
everything is a
4 115 milliamp hour battery
pretty good sized battery and it comes
with
warp charge 30t charger in the box so
you're getting fast charging
that we're used to with other oneplus
phones included
at this price so that's like zero to 70
percent charge in half an hour if you
need it
that is always nice to have now there is
no wireless charging
in this phone there's no official ip
water or dust resistance rating and
while we're at it
there's a couple other places they save
money uh they've used ufs
2.1 storage and they've used usb 2.0
data speeds even though you still have
fast charging so there's
some places where they've cut it back
but if you've been paying attention
you've probably noticed something by now
which is
unlike a lot of the other budget phones
i've reviewed especially lately this
doesn't go super all in on one spec
and then kind of skimp on the rest this
definitely feels like a much more
balanced package the build quality is
definitely here you have metal and glass
you got that alert slider we're used to
the 90 hertz oled display is a great
place to start
you have a pretty good sized battery
with fast charging
a pretty nice set of specs again this
isn't the review but
the 765g has some pretty good
performance results so far
and that's paired with plenty of ram so
maybe with a budget phone you're hearing
all this you're like oh i know so the
camera's trash
right that's usually how it goes cheap
phone cheap camera
here's a scoop on the camera so it is a
quad camera system so you start with a
48 megapixel
main camera an 8 megapixel ultrawide
camera
and then a 2 megapixel macro camera
and then a 5 megapixel depth sensor so
it's like okay they can say it's a
quad camera system but most people most
people are just going to be using
the first two cameras and then the main
camera is actually the same
camera same hardware as the oneplus 8
not the oneplus 8 pro
the oneplus 8 so again this isn't my
review that review will have my
photo samples and video samples from
this camera system
and the selfie cameras you got a 32
megapixel selfie camera
and then a second 8 megapixel ultra wide
selfie camera up front
i got to be testing all those things but
a couple things on the camera one
oneplus has called it like a flagship
quality camera
i wouldn't call it a flagship camera
i'll say the oneplus 8 pro
has what i consider a flagship quality
camera because it's their flagship
and that stays up to par with the
samsungs and apples and
huawei's of the world the oneplus 8
camera if you go back and watch that
review
was a step below that but also oneplus
does have a pretty great track record at
least from my experience of improving
camera quality over time with software
updates
so while this isn't you know the highest
and most amazing camera
this is now a couple months or multiple
months into
the development in this camera system so
it's going to be
better than some of the garbage we've
seen in other 400
android phones and then i do like that
they have dual selfie cameras up here
the one standard one ultra wide
instead of like some borderline useless
depth sensor so if you're going to do
the dual cutout which this is the first
time oneplus has actually ever done
two cameras up front uh you might as
well make use of it so they got the
pillbox cut out
and two cameras so my full analysis of
these cameras
of this new chipset and the performance
and of course all the other stuff the
screen and everything that goes with it
will be in the full review so definitely
get subscribed make sure you're among
the first to see that
if you haven't already but basically if
i'm remembering my first impressions
well enough it's that
this is a pretty promising package
they've kept up
because of that balance a lot of the
fast and smooth stuff
pretty well so the most important thing
left then is availability
so with this first nord phone oneplus is
focusing on
india china and europe so it's not
coming to north america this is your
list of
launch countries here so you can see if
your country is or isn't on that list
not the widest launch ever but we also
learned at least from when i was talking
to carl
in that interview that there will be
more phones later in the nord
lineup with other names that may come to
the united states or to north america
or to other regions that aren't listed
in that graphic
so most people who aren't in those
regions
probably won't get their hands on this
phone probably won't be importing it
because that's not something most people
do and if you can't get your hands on a
nord
which let's face it that's a lot of
people you definitely still have the
option
of these matte pastel skins which are
available across
channel sponsor dbrand's entire device
catalog for every device
so there's probably something in there
for you i'll link it below and i'll just
add that my favorite of these new colors
is their new pastel orange but there you
have it that's everything you need to
know about oneplus nord right off the
jump
my take kind of like i've said is it's
it's that overall steady package of
nothing too crazy but not skimping on
almost anything
a lot of phones in this price range like
if we take out iphone sc
because that's the other giant gorilla
in the room at this exact price
this seems like one of those better
well-rounded things you can get you're
going to get a big battery
fast charging pretty nice screen high
refresh rate
5g compatibility there's a lot going
here turns out the reason people wanted
oneplus to come back to this lower price
and make a device
in this space it's because they're
pretty good at it but anyway full
reviews coming up bunch of other videos
coming up right on the horizon
i feel like we are right about to
descend
into smartphone season like it's it's
rolling over the hill right now
you think you're you think you're safe
but your sub box should be prepared
i'll leave it at that thank you for
watching catch you guys next one
peace